detective check
very happy
all right i think she's here mr
shellhorn thank you officer
judge i'm going to collect these
environments
please doing anything else up on that
witness stand
hi ms gray please remain standing for a
moment please
uh can you place your left hand on the
bible on the witness stand please raise
your right hand please listen to my
quote did you swing the presence of
almighty god that the testimony given to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth yes ma'am please state
your name i'll spell your last name for
the record mary haskins gray and gray
thank you all right have a seat miss
great thank you please keep your voice
up nice and loud absolutely
that microphone records okay does not
amplify
okay okay
no no it's fine right there
that's just for reporting purposes but
it doesn't apply amplify um your voice
throughout the program okay
if you don't understand the question
please don't answer it just indicate you
don't understand
i'll have counsel rephrase the question
so you understand go ahead mr shellhorn
good morning miss greg good morning can
you please introduce yourself to the
jury
um i'm mary haskins gray i'm a
professional guitarist writer and
trainer and competitor
and can you tell us a little bit about
your professional experience as a
dressage rider
in what regards
uh how long have you been riding oh
since i was five
and what is dressage
i would say is like the highest form of
training um we do
sort of dance moves for the horses and
patterns
it's an olympic sport
you can ride at all levels as an amateur
professional
but that's that's my main focus for the
horse is dressage
and did you also indicate you have some
experience as an instructor or a trainer
yes can you tell the jury a little bit
about that
so
i mostly train horses and riders and
then i compete also but i teach lessons
clinics
other
aspiring riders and a lot of times
mostly work with the horses training the
horses
with respect to dressage is there a
difference between being a professional
and an amateur
yes can you tell the jury what that is
so professionals paid for something in
the business whether it's a boarding
business or riding lessons or paid to
ride or compete an amateur someone that
rides
without compensation without money
and what is your status professional
do you know michael garrison yes sir do
you see him in court today yes sir could
you just identify him by an article of
clothing he's wearing uh blue and red
striped high
i've identified my question all right
mr gray has identified the defendant for
the record
mr barrison go ahead mr shelbourne
ms gray do you also know an individual
named lauren canada yes sir did you know
her or do you know her through your
association with mr barrison yes sir do
you know an individual named robert
goodwin yes sir and do you know him
through your same association with the
defense yes sir
can you tell the jury when it is that
you first met uh the defendant michael
barrasso
um when i first met him i was probably a
teenager
through
competing internationally and running
the same circuit we knew of each other
through mutual friends and other
professionals
and at some point uh
during your life were you involved in a
romantic relationship yes sir and do you
recall approximately when that began
um 2015 sometime
and drawing your attention to the uh
summer of 2019 were you still involved
in a relationship with him uh
romantically yes sir were you also
involved in a professional relationship
yes sir can you tell the jury what the
nature of that relationship was
professional yes
so i had horses in the barn in new
jersey and in florida
we worked together
developing horses for top sport bringing
along young horses
we worked on personal goals
training our students and clients and
all of that
now you indicated that
there were two farms can you tell the
jury specifically where those two farms
were
one one is in long valley new jersey and
the other in loxahatchee florida
and
what is your understanding of why the
defendant owned two farms
it's pretty common
or at least to travel between north and
south because obviously the weather
changes and to keep
developing the horses training and
competing a lot of people will go south
for the winter and north for the summer
that's pretty common
based on your involvement with the
defendant both professionally and
romantically
are you aware of certain aspects of his
business and of his farms
yes
for example can you tell the jury
of how many horses may be boarded at the
new jersey farm at any given time
um i think towards the end we had about
40 to 45 on the new jersey farm we
didn't have that much room in florida
but
about what we had in new jersey and
would 40 to 45 be about capacity for
what that
could board yes
did the defendant ever have employees or
students working for him yes and can you
tell the jury what a student
worker would be in the dressage
community like a working student yes
okay so that's also pretty common
working students are
people that are typically younger or
want to want to learn and
follow someone that's more accomplished
so they'll put themselves in a working
situation where they exchange work for
education so that's pretty common in the
horse industry to have younger people
come and stay
work learn progress most of them go on
to become professionals themselves and
during the time that you were working
with the defendant approximately how
many working students may be there at
any given time i'd say about four
roughly
give or take
what is a writing clinic
a clinic um
is usually where the instructor travels
to another farm or location and teaches
multiple writers per day it's usually a
lot of auditors
it's usually someone also super
accomplished teaching people that are
looking to further their education and
their riding with their horse and
that's pretty much it and does the
clinician uh get paid for that yes sir
what is your understanding or experience
with
how a clinician is paid
what do you mean by check or like i
don't know what do you
uh
is it do they get paid a lot of money a
little amount of money or something else
i would say depending on the person and
their accomplishments it can be
typically people that have been the
olympics are usually charged pretty high
amount
are you aware of what michael
barrasson's reputation was in the
dressage community yes sir
what were some of his accomplishments
that you're aware of as a writer yes um
competed internationally very
successfully um alternate olympic games
pretty much what we all strive to
accomplish as a writer he had done it
did you ever see him coaching at any
clinics
uh yes yeah
and what was your
experience or what was your observations
of him and the way that he would coach
and be received by the people at the
clinic he was a very popular in love
clinician
now in terms of the farm here in long
valley in new jersey where did you live
when you were here
on the farm
and can you describe for the jury a
little bit about uh what was on the
property of the farm
well there was a historical home um
there was
a barn with 30 some stalls
indoor riding arena outdoor riding arena
alternate buildings with additional
stalls
a young horse area where we had young
horses that lived outside
hay fields
when you say a historical farm can you
tell the jury a little bit about the
layout uh of the farm it's me of the
farmhouse
um well from what i understand it was a
house that was closer up to the road
that they moved further back
and actually turned into three different
living areas
did you ever live in that house i did
and at times were there other people
living in that house besides just you
yes sir uh for example when you lived
there did you live in one of those
living areas with anybody
yes sir who was that michael barrerson
and my children when they were here
so you have children yes sir is that uh
with the defendant or with someone else
or someone else do they live in another
place most of the year
uh most like when they're in school
they're mostly in north carolina i guess
and so i guess from the answer you just
gave at times they would come to the
near new jersey farm absolutely yeah and
they would stay with you at the
farmhouse yes sir
who else may have lived uh in the the
farmhouse for example when you were
living there when i was living there
lauren and rob were living upstairs
are you aware if anyone else had ever
lived in that upstairs apartment yes who
was that justin hardin
now you said that there were
approximately three separate living
areas yes what was the third living area
um originally there was a basement there
was entrance to the basement where a lot
of the girls would live we had a little
kitchen and bedrooms and bathroom down
there um the main floor was a separate
entrance in residence and then upstairs
had its own entrance and that was his
own residence as well
and were those separate although they
each had separate entrances to those
various living areas were they also
connected within the inside of the
building yes
now you also mentioned uh the barn and
the training areas yes can you describe
a little bit more detail about what was
in that area of the farm
inside the barn
well uh
there was a stable yes so yeah and this
table we had tack rooms we had like a
big loading dock where we kept hey a
feed room
attached to the stable was a covered
arena
and so we're like a grooming area you
can go right into the ring or outside
the outdoor arena we had a big clubhouse
with a kitchen
um an office
and you just used the word word tack
room for those members of the jury who
don't know what a tack room is what's
that
that's where you keep your saddle and
bridle and
all your horse tack and then we also had
lockers where people had
grooming supplies and miscellaneous
things
judge i'd like to show the witness a
number of
photos going to identify those
for the record
our s290
s291
s293
s294
s295
s297
s300
and s289 judge
what have you seen those mr belinkus yes
right those items will be received in
the evidence it's uh 289 290 291 293 294
295 297.
300
all in evidence go ahead i may have
neglected to say s292 i apologize all
right any objection to that mr belenkus
blencus
all right s 292 is an evidence as well
and may be displayed to the jury
all right ms greg you were just uh
describing the
uh
the clubhouse at the barn uh we just
pulled up on the screen here s 289 do
you recognize that i do um have you seen
all these photos uh before coming to
court yes sir and what is s 289 a
picture of um our club room area
and does that appear to be a fair and
accurate picture of the way the club
room looked on august 7 2018
with respect to s289
what would be at the back of the the
photo meaning if someone was standing
looking into the room what's at their
back the back left corner would be the
office
okay so looking to the to the back left
corner of this picture is the office yes
sir okay and is that where you could see
a little bit of a light next to that
pillar
what would be to the right of the office
there
inside the club room
that door
is there a pool table in that room there
is yes okay and what's uh in the pool
table closer to where the picture is
taking couches
furniture and as we come closer to where
the picture's taken what's on the left
hand side dining room table
more furniture
in your kitchen and then the kitchen and
then if someone was to turn around and
walk backwards in the direction where
the phone is the door that goes out
hold on wait for me to answer the
question i know you're anxious yes
let him finish
it's not it's for the jury it's also for
the record so everybody hears the
question fully
and even though oftentimes witnesses
anticipate what's going to be said just
let them finish so the jury hears it
then then you can answer all right go
ahead rephrase your question
so if someone was to turn around to the
direction where the photo was taken and
turn around and walk backwards what
would be behind them a door that goes
into the barn
and what as you walk through that door
what do you see when you get into that
area to the left would be
two tack rooms to the right with the
lockers would start there
now i'm gonna show you s290
uh what do you recognize s290 to be a
picture of um that's the entrance from
the porch into like a fourier that went
into the cupboard
so would this be if uh someone was
walking into the club room from the
entrance on the parking lot yes sir
what are those
uh items that are hanging from a chain
and hook there on the
the middle of the picture those are
coolers or blankets from competition um
usually international competitions and
top placings
and what's so what's the significance of
a what is
um i think maybe some are like
scrum sheets but they sometimes they'll
give you a cooler it's like something
you throw over the horses
cool or warm and sweating or you want to
draw them off
um a lot of times if you want a
competition they would give you a blank
blanket for the horse so some of those
might be
sheets
and are you aware of what some of these
specific coolers were for that were
hanging or who had won those coolers
yes sir who would that be i would assume
most of them belong to michael garrison
and do you assume that because you've
had conversations or you knew that from
living there yeah i mean vera had done
some things too so i don't know like
which ones exactly belong to each person
who is vera michael's ex-wife and is
that vera kessels yes sir
do you know approximately how long the
defendant and vera kessels were married
i do not
at some point are you aware whether she
lived on that property yes sir
and she is also involved in the
equestrian and dressage
i'll next show you uh what's been marked
as s 291
what is this a picture of
this same thing on the other side so
this is the other side of that foyer
that you talked about yes and are those
also
coolers that are hanging there as well
yes sir so is it fair to say if someone
came to the property for the first time
walked
into the building from the parking lot
this would be the first thing they would
see as they come into the club correct
all right next i'm going to ask you uh
what is s 292 a picture of
also the club room
and what vantage point would this be
taken from coming into the club um if
you've just walked in from the porch
that would be looking to the left
are there also some coolers hanging over
there sort of in the between the windows
yes
what do those windows look at that are
on the right hand side of the picture um
the windows look out into the indoor
arena
and seating area out there where
we would sit
with respect to some of the photos that
we see on the left hand side of the the
picture and then in the middle of the
picture as well as down on the window
sills what what are those pictures of
generally
um
big accomplishments um
great horses that were made
some some of those on the left are of
olympians that michael coached
his pictures with the olympic team
[Music]
some of the pictures up top are of young
horses that were purchased
and when you say great horses that were
made what do you mean by that um
horses that were competed at the highest
level
had done
major championships or
competed internationally that were
successful and would those be horses
that were trained by michael barrasson
or at his farm yes sir and both like
some of the riders on the left had
horses of their own that he was involved
with stuff like that
all right next i'll uh
show you
what's been marked as s293 is this just
another picture moving further into the
center of the room
yes it is and are those pictures up on
the top
above the window the pictures you were
talking about the young horses yes sir
can you tell that explain that the
significance of that again to the jury
um you mean as far as the significance
of the business or
what would what what is the significance
of the pictures what are the pictures
they were of foals that were purchased
either at auction um or through a friend
of a family member
and that's definitely not all of the
young horses that we have but horses
that have been acquired and we have
pictures off of the foals the baby
horses
and then what would the significance be
of putting those pictures up in the club
room there where people could see them
i don't think it's had any significance
other than it was meaningful to us
i guess fair to say you were proud of
what you had done
well nothing had been done with those
yet they were they were babies so that
was just usually at auction they'll send
you a picture with a passport and so we
just displayed them
of horses for the future
and is s294 just another picture moving
to the right
correct where does that doorway go
that
door goes out into the indoor arena
and if a person wants to walk through
that door and into the indoor arena what
is right in front of them
inside the area a seating area and a
little
a wall like i had well to the arena
chairs
is s295 another picture of uh that room
moving towards the right yes sir and i
see a door to the right of this picture
there
uh
where does that door go the door on the
far right is the door that goes out into
the barn area that was the one that you
had explained before you would go out to
where there's the tack room and the
water
what was this club room used for
um
a common area we all had breakfast and
coffee and dinners and
it's just a common area for clients and
us to enjoy
uh at times was it used for entertaining
yeah for sure
in s295 on the right there
is that the table you were talking about
the dining room table yes yes sir
and a last question on this photo in the
back
i guess on the right side just to the
left of the
door
it looks like there's some sort of a
shadow box or a frame can you tell the
jury what that is
um those it was just awards for um those
were mine actually
they were ribbons and i think
medals maybe from a championship
all right we'll
go on to s 296. what's that a floodwall
also the club room and again is this
looking back in the direction of the
doorway out to the parking lot and the
office yes sir
and on the left hand side of this
picture
what's hanging on the wall in those
shadow boxes or frames more awards and
accomplishments and do you recall who's
whose those were specifically the two in
the middle were mine and the two on the
side
were michael and orveras
and his sns 297
is obviously a picture of the kitchen
you described yes sir
now uh s298 is this a picture from the
opposite side of the club room looking
back in the direction where we just were
yes sir
it's probably
hard to tell from the picture but can
you describe in s299 what this is uh in
the bottom of the picture
what's the piece of furniture a full
table
and last i'm going to show you s
300 do you recognize that picture
i do yeah is that just another picture
of a different area of the club room yes
sir
what if you recall were in some of those
photos that you see on the left hand
side there
those were clients
some of the ladies on their horses
he would have anyone that had competed
grand prix give us a picture
and he'd been collecting those over the
years so students
clients personal horses stuff like that
and is that um there's some black and
white photos on the left there closer to
the door you know what those were photos
of i think horses from his childhood is
motherhood maybe
all right now you indicated that there's
also an office in the barn yes sir
if we were looking at s 300 where would
the office be oriented in relation to
where we are in s300 um so if i'm
standing right here looking at the
picture it would be to the right
so it looks like there's a bookcase on
the right side of the picture yes sir
would it be to the right just past there
it would
um whose office was that
michael's and i had a desk in there as
well
all right i'm going to show you what's
been marked as s-301 that i believe is
already in evidence
uh is that a picture of the office it is
and you indicated that you had a
workspace in there where was your
desktop to the right like right when you
walked in it was to the right side
so it looks like there's a chair there
on wheels yes sir would that be the
chair you're talking about where you
would sit yes sir
and who would sit at that big desk
behind you michael would
what's s-302 a picture of the office as
well looking out
into the cover
now on the right-hand side what's that
big black item
the safe
not necessarily everything
did you have access on a regular basis
to the safety no sir
now before i move on um do you and
michael barazone still have any sort of
a business relationship no sir
now i think you indicated that you had
met uh mr barrissone quite some time ago
and uh did you know many of the same
people in the industry we did we do yeah
and how would you describe the
equestrian community in terms of uh
i guess size or familiarity
i think everyone's pretty familiar with
one another if you're after a certain
point yes
during the course of of time that you
knew the defendant worked with them and
were involved in a romantic relationship
with them did you communicate with him
on a regular basis
yes not not before we were in a
relationship yeah but when you were yes
sir and would that have been
uh through various means in person over
the phone and through text message sure
now judge may i approach yes
[Music]
once again just let him finish okay
thank you and that was august 7 2019
yes sir and you recall uh what kind of
phone it was maybe not the specific an
iphone
um judge might have permission to move s
uh 176 into evidence any objections on s
176 isn't evidence yes so if you could
open that
and is that your phone that you gave to
the police yes
and you can put it back in there thank
you
and you're aware
uh or you became aware after giving that
to the police at some point in the last
amount of time since the shooting
that that phone was processed by the
police of course yes and you understand
that they had extracted certain
absolutely yes
evidence from it yes
now during the course of time that you
and the defendant were working together
and involved in a relationship together
did you discuss various things related
to the equestrian world sure and that
would have involved
things that were going on maybe with
other people in the equestrian community
sure
did you discuss
uh things related to the business and
running the farm absolutely
at times um
now you indicated that the defendant was
also your coach yes sir and is it fair
to say
that based on the fact that you were
involved in a relationship with him you
were running a business with him and
that you were being coached by him
you're aware of some of his philosophies
on horsemanship and that sort of sure
that's right can you tell the jury what
horsemanship is
i think everyone would describe that
differently um horsemanship to me would
be everything that goes into managing a
horse
everything down to the grooming the barn
the
feed the veterinary care the barrier
and then
also doing and taking as much time you
need to develop the horse in the most
correct way
what was the defendant's view on
horsemanship
he put a big importance on horsemanship
judge at this point if i could have a
breakout room
to show uh some text messages to ms gray
sure
judge for the record this is marked as
s-171
is greg can you see that screen in front
of you i can
so just so you know that this item has
been marked for identification so we can
keep track of it with the record at this
point
but we won't be displaying it up on the
screen so just you'll be able to see it
so if you need us at some point to
make it bigger okay to make it easier to
see then just tell me
and i'm going to direct your attention
to
uh line 6 7 7 8 of s 171
do you see that line
um
tell me the number one more time please
six seven seven eight if you look
there's a little cursor next to it and
does that indicate that it was a text
message that michael barrasson the
defendant sent you on february 17 2019.
correct
and uh what did he say uh in that second
line of that text message
judge again
i have no objection as long as i can get
into specific conversations
all right um
it's quarter of
we'll take our morning break ladies and
gentlemen it's right around that time
um
we have to discuss this legal issue so
we'll take about 20 minutes so
1105 or so so use the facilities you
want to get coffee if there's coffee
around you can do that please don't
discuss the case and we'll see you about
1105. thank you
you may step down okay
you